la campagne de vaccination française le
feu des critiques se poursuit le
gouvernement espère un coup
d'accélérateur avec l'arrivée
aujourd'hui des premières doses du
vaccin astrazeneca au total 273 1612
seront répartis à partir à d'aujourd'hui
entre 117 établissements dont sept dans
les outre mer la livraison suivante est
prévue la semaine prochaine avec plus de
300 mille doses
le vaccin va être injecté en priorité à
des soignants de moins de 65 ans selon
les recommandations de la haute autorité
de santé
et hier nous avons franchi la barre des
2 millions de vaccinations selon jean
castex
le premier ministre a pour l'heure nous
disposons de trois vaccins en europe
faiza biotech moderna et astrazeneca
ecoutez jean jacques en brousse qui les
médecins hospitaliers l'hôpital bichat
économiste de la santé à l'université
paris descartes
finalement on est passé d'une phase et
on l'a bien vu en france par exemple de
grandes réticences impute deux tiers des
français ne voulaient pas se faire
vacciner a au contraire un grand
engouement
or finalement la mise au point d'une
usine des différentes phases de
production des vaccins en particulier
les vaccins totalement nouveaux que sont
les vaccins biotech kaiser et moderna
nécessite une un agrément non seulement
la la construction d'unités de
fabrication et de conditionnement
spécialisés mais un agrément de ces
ateliers par les autorités de santé les
différents pays et finalement la
procédure d'agrément est longue délicate
s'agit pas simplement de faire une
inspection rapide et à l'issue d'un tour
de deux ou trois heures d'un atelier de
tamponner c'est ce sont des procédures
de vérification et de contrôle qui pour
certaines prennent plusieurs semaines
plusieurs semaines veut dire plus d'un
mois dans certains cas et lorsque l'
usine de perth en belgique qui
appartient à pfizer et qui entre en
charge des deux dernières phases du fai
fabrication du vaccin biotech kaiser a
souhaité agrandir pour répondre au mieux
à la demande importante et bien il a
fallu attendre non seulement que les
travaux soient faits quelques jours mais
que l'agrément soit donnée ce qui encore
une fois prend du temps
le succès de ces vaccins explique le
délai que mettent les unités de
production à s'adapter
où que ce soit dans le monde et plus
particulièrement celles qui servent les
clients européens que nous sommes
la situation sanitaire est stable avec
un léger recul de la pression
hospitalière pour la troisième journée
consécutive selon les chiffres publiés
hier on l'a relevé 22 milles 130
nouveaux patients des convives 19 la
pandémie a fait près de 2,3 millions de
morts dans le monde dont 13 mois c'est
un bilan établi par l'afp à partir de
sources officielles plus de 105 millions
de cas d'infections ont été
diagnostiqués depuis décembre 2019
toujours l'inquiétude à propos de
l'évolution des variants des variantes
qui représente 21 % des nouveaux cas en
france alors poids augmente de près de
50% chaque semaine à ce rythme c'est
variante pourrait même devenir dominante
d'ici quelques semaines selon santé
publique france et face à cela comment
réagir comment sauver la france à la
fois sur le plan sanitaire et économique
une équation très délicate
on en a parlé avec un bruno mais garbani
les chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
trouver le juste équilibre et rythmant
il faut pas que les priorités sanitaires
l'emportent sur tout le reste
mais à l'inversé évidemment il faut
permettre aux services hospitaliers
d'offrir des thérapeutiques optimale à
toutes les personnes qui le nécessitent
il est ou non la co vide je crois que
malgré tout on paye des années de
politique de santé
on va dire qu'il n'était guidé que par
des objectifs comptables
effectivement nous payons aujourd'hui
ces fermetures de lui ces diminutions du
nombre de personnels et les alertes qui
sont lancés aujourd'hui par les
administrateurs des hôpitaux sont eux
qui ont appliqué cette politique et qui
maintenant s'en mordre les doigts
et puis cette autre question comment
augmenter massivement la production des
vaccins à l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a plaide en faveur du partage des
technologies
l'om est cite l'exemple du groupe
pharmaceutique français sanofi qui a
pris du retard dans le développement de
son propre vaccin mais a proposé son
aide pour conduire celui de son
concurrent pfizer ben t'as qu'à partir
de cet été
écoutez le patron de l' oms les pays
sont prêts mais les vaccins ne sont pas
là nous avons besoin que les pays
partagent des doses une fois qu'ils ont
fini de vacciner les personnels de santé
et les personnes âgées
mais nous avons également besoin d'une
augmentation massive de la production la
semaine dernière sanofi a annoncé qu'il
mettrait à disposition son
infrastructure de fabrication pour
soutenir la production du vaccin
fighters green tech
nous appelons les autres entreprises à
suivre cet exemple
oui carlo nadal quand par exemple le
brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé par la pandémie à de koné 19
une lueur d'espoir là-bas pour les
habitants des dix plus grandes favelas
face à la pauvreté et au chômage
une banque communautaire va être lancé à
la fin du mois on voit cela avec quentin
mauclair des dizaines de repas prêts à
être distribués dans cette favela de
pareilles sow police à sao paulo
la pandémie de que vite 19 à amplifier
la pauvreté et le chômage parmi les
habitants conséquence ils sont nombreux
à faire la queue devant les banques
alimentaires et lors des distributions
de vêtements
j'ai beaucoup de difficultés en ce
moment aujourd'hui par exemple si je
voulais un réal pour m'acheter du pain
je ne l'aurais pas pour redonner de
l'espoir à tous et brésiliens paupériser
les dix plus grandes favelas du pays
s'associent pour créer une banque
communautaire
cette banque du g10 verra le jour à la
fin du mois de février
elle permettra aux brésiliens les plus
pauvres d'avoir une carte de crédit
selon l' institute aux locomotives à 45
millions de brésiliens ne possède pas de
compte en banque soit un adulte sur
trois autres objectifs de la banque
communautaire accorder des micro crédits
aux entreprises
nos recherches montrent que quart
pour cent des habitants des favelas ce
rêve de créer leur propre entreprise
nous devons donc leur permettre de
réaliser ses rêves appareils sont polis
et dans les autres favelas du brésil
afin que leurs habitants puissent
étudier travailler et être les acteurs
de ces changements et pour que le rêve
puisse s'accomplir
le projet de banque du g10 va même au
delà du simple prêt d'argent
il vise aussi à promouvoir le
développement d'économie locale le
crédit permettra aux nouveaux
entrepreneurs de passer à l'action et
d'avoir un revenu et il permettra à ceux
qui sont déjà entrepreneurs d'atteindre
des objectifs plus ambitieux qui
créeront plus de revenus et feront
circuler plus d'argent circulant à
l'intérieur de la communauté
l'idée n'est pas seulement de fournir
des crédits qu mais aussi d'avoir des
outils éducatifs est de les aider à
atteindre leurs objectifs
la banque communautaire aura un capital
initial de 1,8 millions de reals soit
280 mille euros des économistes et des
finances et seront aux côtés de
l'organisme pour le conseiller
un tiers des bénéfices de la banque
serviront ensuite à financer des
programmes sociaux à l'image de ceux qui
ont émergé depuis le début de la
pandémie on venezuela touché par la
pandémie également on a trouvé le moyen
d'éviter les files d'attentes
interminables devant les bancs des
autobus sont transformés en bureaux de
change est cela se passa à caracas la
capitale dans ses autobus privés les
habitants s'approvisionnaient en devises
locales
ils payent leur ticket en dollars en
leur rend la monnaie en bolivars en
raison de la quantité de dollars que
nous recevons nous devons les payés en
dessous du niveau du prix établi par le
marché car ils nous enlèvent
complètement le peu d'argent que nous
recevons nous sommes le seul
établissement commercial
en d'autres termes qui dispose de
liquidités car les banques n'ont pas la
capacité de livrer des liquidités aux
utilisateurs nous sommes donc devenus
des bureaux de change dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire le premier tour de la
présidentielle va se tenir en équateur
lundi en lice trois candidats se
démarquent
ils veulent rompre avec la politique
libérale actuelle du président lenin
moreno on voit cela avec amaya s'oublie
c'est le grand favori de cette élection
présidentielle en equateur andres arrose
candidat socialiste est en tête des
sondages avec 32% des intentions de vote
arrivé sur le devant de la scène
politique récemment le jeune économiste
était méconnu du grand public il y a
encore six mois le candidat de la
coalition union pour l'espérance est
soutenu par l'ancien chef de l'état
rafael correa
ce qui explique en grande partie sa
popularité son objectif rompre avec la
politique du gouvernement du président
lenin moreno à quito où il a terminé sa
campagne entouré de ses nombreux
soutiens
il a promis un scrutin en un seul tour
et une grande victoire populaire pour la
vie pour la dignité
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici et
c'est pour cela que nous allons
remporter une grande victoire populaire
ce dimanche 7 février
[Musique]
parmi les 16 candidats à la présidence
deux autres figures se démarque lierre
molas aux ex banquier et représentants
de la droite conservatrice se présente
pour la troisième fois la magistrature
suprême
il prône une démocratie totale et en
équateur d'opportunités comme un symbole
témoins
à la fin je serai avec ma famille chez
moi plein de paix en attendant les
résultats
ils vont être positif ils le seront
certainement le peuple équatorien on a
assez des quatorze ans de socialisme au
21ème siècle dernières figures qui s'est
démarqué de cette campagne
présidentielle yakou perez voir tant
belle militants écologistes incarne la
défense des droits des indigènes avec
son parti de gauche pachakutik avocats
de 51 ans fervent militant des droits
humains
il combat depuis toujours la politique
d'austérité du gouvernement actuel
je suis toujours un militant et je vais
le rester
c'est dans mes gènes je porte ce là dans
mon coeur mais aujourd'hui la préfecture
provincial est pour moi un instrument un
outil pour défendre mon peuple pour
qu'il échappe à l'état colonial et
hiérarchique qui impose ses décisions
le pays s'apprête à élire son nouveau
président dans un contexte d'endettement
et de crise financière aggravée par la
pandémie de coronavirus guillermo olaso
et yacou perez récoltent respectivement
21 % et 10 % des intentions de vote
pour l'emporter dès le premier tour en
dresse à rose devra obtenir au moins 40
% des voix un scénario peu probable pour
les analystes ce qui entraînerait la
tenue d'un second tour le 11 avril
prochain
le tchadien moussa faki mahamat réélu
pour quatre ans à la tête de l'union
africaine 50 états des 55 membres ont
voté pour lui l'organisation
panafricaine qui a ouvert aujourd'hui un
sommet virtuel de deux jours au menu des
discussions la crise de lakovic 19 les
plans de vaccination pour le continent
mais également de nombreuses questions
peut traiter ces derniers mois en raison
de l'urgence sanitaire lors de sa prise
de parole le président sud africain
cyril ramaphosa a loué je cite l'unité
la solidarité de l'afrique dans la
gestion de la pandémie siens en tunisie
la rue restent mobilisés contre les
restrictions sanitaires et l'absence de
changements réels depuis la révolution
du jasmin il ya dix ans un des
manifestants demandent la libération
d'autres incarcéré lors des précédentes
mobilisations
on va écouter quelques uns d'entre eux
au micro de notre reporter bassam chez
bis
aujourd'hui c'est le 6 février
ce une dette
très importante et très significative
pour nous et mais aussi c'est la
continuité de la série d'une série des
manifs qu'entre
les agressions policières qu'on a vécu
tout au long du mois de janvier
si dix ans après la révolution on ait
affronté une politique aussi polisseur
est aussi agressif que ça on n'a rien
fait en fait tout le peuple a constaté
qu'il ya un retour à l'arrière sur la
seule chose qu'on a gagné de la
révolution qui est la liberté
d'expression la liberté de se manifester
le peuple doit prendre marc les choses
et doit récupérer sa révolution volée un
bond de profiteurs qui veulent une chose
est seule chose c'est rester au pouvoir
quel que soit le prix les phares sein du
maréchal râler faf tard l'homme fort de
l'est de la libye y ont félicité
aujourd'hui le peuple libyen pour
l'issue du dialogue politique qui s'est
tenue à genève hier sous l'égide de
l'onu à conseil présidentiel et un
premier ministre par intérim ont été
élues objectif mettre en place un
gouvernement à préparer des élections
nationales fin décembre et mettre fin à
dix ans de chaos et de violence on voit
cela avec françois de la ville en bas
les négociations entre les participants
au dialogue interlibyen ont donc abouti
dans un lieu tenu secret en suisse
ils ont désigné un candidat surprise
adoul hamid behbahani 39 fois sur 73
originaires de misrata cet ingénieur a
notamment présidé la compagnie libyenne
d'investissement et de développement
sous le règne de mouammar kadhafi
ce premier ministre désigné devra dans
un délai ne dépassant pas 20 jours
former son gouvernement selon l'onu il
aura également la lourde tâche de
réunifier les institutions et
d'organiser les élections nationales
programmée le 24 décembre prochain nous
surveillerons ce que vous avez désigné
pour nous assurer qu'ils rendront le
pouvoir au peuple libyen le 24 décembre
de cette année afin d'élire
démocratiquement les représentants et
les dirigeants politiques de la libye
si la désignation du nouveau premier
ministre
remarque d'avancé la situation politique
libyenne reste chaotique deux autorités
se disputent toujours les rênes du pays
d'un côté le gouvernement d'union
nationale reconnue par l'onu et jusqu
alors dirigé par faïza sa rage de
l'autre à pouvoir incarner par rallye
faf tard l'homme soutenue par le
parlement de tout groupe qui contrôle
l'est du territoire
après de nombreux affrontements les deux
camps ont conclu un cessez le feu en
octobre dernier pour s'assurer d'une
transition réussie en libye le conseil
de sécurité a ordonné le déploiement
d'observateurs sur place onze mois avant
la tenue d'un scrutin crucial pour
l'avenir du pays
et quelles sont les chances à du nouvel
exécutif unis pour sortir le pays du
chaos
écoutez riadh sidaoui les directeurs du
qu'arabe ce centre arabe de recherches
et des analyses politiques et sociales à
genève en suisse
bien que hier 1075t lesquels à genève
dans 73 ont participé et monsieur habib
ben hiba a gagné pas on off je pense aux
lois alors la grande question d'ordre
structurel et a eu les soixante quinze
délégués qui sont présents à genève il a
eu lui qui le peuple est bien évidemment
non donc il ya un grand problème d'ordre
structurel
à mon avis ce qui s'est passé à genève
cyr pour cette question doit être
résolue par le consensus
je répète par consensus ce qui autorise
aussi aux politiques
ça veut dire pas des lycées et des
élections entre 75 délégués que nous ne
savons pas qui les a nommés à la cour
pénale internationale s'est dit
compétente pour juger des crimes commis
dans les territoires palestiniens
occupés
une annonce hier soir de la cour qui
siège à la haye aux pays-bas l'instance
précise que cela ne remet pas en cause
les frontières entre israël et la
palestine mais ouvre la voie à une
enquête pour crimes de guerre le
clarations saluée par les autorités
palestiniennes et dénoncé par à l'état
hébreu cette décision est une victoire
pour la justice et l'humanité pour les
valeurs de vérité d'équité de liberté et
pour le son des victimes et de leurs
familles
aujourd'hui le tribunal a une nouvelle
fois prouvé qu'il est un organe
politique est pas une institution
judiciaire
hier le tribunal ignore les véritables
crimes de guerre-- poursuit à la place
l'état d'israël un état avec un régime
démocratique solide qui sanctifie d'état
de droit et n'est pas un membre du
tribunal
et pour françois constantine et
géopolitologue cette décision de la cpi
permet à l'autorité palestinienne de
marquer un point il sera difficile
d'avoir une enquête sur le terrain
je pense que c'est uniquement de façon
symbolique un appel à la juridiction
pénale internationale qui a voulu faire
l'autorité palestinienne là dessus elle
a marqué un point mais on peut tout à
fait sans s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
sur le terrain et de façon effective
aucune enquête qui se déroule israël
peut objecter en effet qu'il n'est pas
signataire qui ne ne surent qui n'est
pas impliquée en effet par la cpi alors
que les statuts de la cpi prévoit en
effet qu on peut aller au delà des
dessinateurs et ils objectera bien sûr
que le l'enquète n'a pas lieu d'être
et comme j'ai dit il faut attendre en
effet à ce que les juges soient
vraisemblement bloqué lors de leur
entrée dans les territoires palestiniens
puisqu'il faut passer par israël pour
entrer dans les territoires palestiniens
mais les rebelles houthi du yémen ne
sont plus considérés comme terroristes
par les états unis l'administration
baden en a informé le congrès la halle
est revenu sur une décision prise par
donald trump il y a quelques semaines
elle prend le contre-pied de ses
prédécesseurs en se dégageant des
opérations offensives de la commission
saoudienne
l italie a fait de même mais la france
tarde à suivre on voit cela avec katia
technique
c'est un tournant dans la diplomatie
américaine celle pratiquée par donald
trump bien sûr mais aussi celle de
barack obama
sous l'impulsion de joe biden les états
unis mettent fin à leur soutien à la
coalition menée par l'arabie saoudite
dans le conflit au yémen
il s'assurait en effet 73 % de l'apport
en armes soit rachetée cette guerre doit
cesser et pour souligner notre
engagement nous cessons tout soutien
américain aux opérations offensives de
la guerre au yémen incluant les ventes
d'armes qui correspondent
la vente d'art maria d abou dhabi qui
mènent la coalition anti rebelles au
yémen
donc temporairement interrompue ainsi
que celles d'avions de chasse le nouveau
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken veut retirer urgemment les
outils de la liste noire américaine des
organisations terroristes ou donald
trump les avait placés juste avant de
quitter le pouvoir l'administration by
john souhaite éviter de bloquer
l'acheminement de convois humanitaires
cette guerre civile sanglante à débuter
en 2014
elle oppose le pouvoir aux mains du
président abd rabbo mansour hadi outil
un mouvement rebelles yéménites chiite
appuyé par l'iran
contrôlant le nord ouest du pays pour le
moment les différents pourparlers n'ont
abouti qu'à des cessez le feu temporaire
peut respecter
l'acheminement des denrées humanitaires
est entré souvent entravée provoquant
des famines dans un pays dont les
pouvoirs publics ont cessé de
fonctionner
l'arabie saoudite concernés au premier
chef puisque c'est elle vont être rognés
s'est dit favorable à une solution
politique plutôt qu'à une poursuite de
la guerre leur enlisement au yémen
constitue une véritable épine dans le
pied du royaume du prince ben salman et
le pouvoir saoudien a de quoi acquiescé
car les restrictions américaines ne
concerne que les opérations offensives
sur le yémen les états unis continueront
à soutenir ryad contre al qaïda dans la
péninsule arabique mais aussi contre les
attaques de drones domicile de groupes
armés soutenus par l'iran tels que les
outils qui menacerait donc sa
souveraineté les outils agacé par le
fait que le soutien subsistent pour les
opérations défensives ont tout de même
salué les annonces de jobs haydn par la
voix de leur porte parole le début de
l'agression contre le yémen a été
annoncé par washington tandis que la fin
du soutien aux ventes d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite a été annoncée par les états
unis ce qui signifie qu'ils sont le
principal instigateur de l'agression
contre les yéménites et ceux qui peuvent
mettre fin à la guerre et aux ventes
d'armes au yémen et comme une bonne
nouvelle n'arrive jamais seule les
italiens entend pointer le pas aux
américains ils cessent eux aussi leur
van damme au royaume concernés 12700
bond ne seront pas livrés et la france
alors vous savez le pays qui selon la
ministre des armées florence parly ne
vend que des armes défensives aux
saoudiens et aux émirats n'est ce pas à
ma connaissance les armes qui ont été
vendues récemment ne sont pas utilisées
contre les populations civiles
or le collectif de journalistes
investigation disclose avait exhumé une
note de la direction du renseignement
militaire datant de septembre 2018
elles avaient révélé l'ampleur réelle de
la commande et identifier ces zones
d'utilisation cette note signalait que
l'arsenal livré pouvait servir de
manière offensive et non simplement
défensive
selon disclose parfaitement au courant
de cette note la france risque de se
rendre complice de crimes de guerre
sachant que les ventes d'armes de la
france à l'arabie saoudite et aux
émirats occupé de 2015 à 2019
respectivement la troisième et la
cinquième place amnesty international
somme paris de cesser ses ventes d'armes
décriée par le biais d'une pétition
adressée à emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
face à l'opacité des ventes d'armes
autorisé par le seul pouvoir exécutif et
l'absence de tout contrôle parlementaire
véritable personne n'est en mesure
d'assurer que la france respecte ses
engagements internationaux
bien sûr c'est assez coûteux de perdre
de juteuses vente d'armes mais il serait
bon de jouer la partition des italiens
retour en france paris 2024 les jeux
olympiques c'est dans trois ans et en
région parisienne plus particulièrement
en seine saint denis la construction de
nombreuses infrastructures sont prévues
dont celle qui doit accueillir le
village des médias dans une partie du
parc départemental georges valbon
plusieurs associations ont déposé un
recours devant la cour administrative de
paris pour demander l'annulation de la
cession du terrain par le conseil
départemental est la justice à a rejeté
le recours il ya eu un rassemblement
aujourd'hui à paris les précisions avec
notre reporter monnaie abdellah et ils
ont un peu plus d'une cinquantaine à
s'être rassemblés devant l'hôtel de
ville pour protester contre l es jeux
olympiques en 2024 qui se dérouleront
dans le département de la seine saint
denis dans le 93 de plusieurs
associations et partis politiques
étaient présents ils ont répondu à
l'appel du groupe elle sa cage et comme
son nom l indique est bien il dénonce un
saccage écologique un saccage politiques
et sociales
urbaniste également je vous propose
d'écouter danielle simonnet de la france
insoumise qui étaient ici
et qui a bien voulu répondre à nos
questions écoutez j'ai été contre les
jeux olympiques dès le premier jour
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus la fête
des sponsors que la fête du sport
c'est toujours une facture énorme qui
sera payé par le peuple au détriment des
investissements nécessaires pour le
quotidien
et là on le voit bien les jeux
olympiques on nous les promet écologique
alors qu'en fait dans 93 on va bousiller
les jardins ouvriers
on va empiéter sur la courneuve on va
imposer un échangeur de l'autoroute a1
qui va aggraver la pollution des écoles
de autour et tout ça pour finalement des
profits toujours pour les mêmes grosses
multinationales et la facture elle
augmente toujours plus je pense qu'il
faut que la mobilisation et je pense
qu'elle montera petit à petit monde
qu'il ya d'autres priorités aujourd'hui
que de claquer l'argent public dans les
jeux olympiques
aujourd'hui il faut absolument qu'on
tire les enseignements aussi de la
pandémie pour se rendre compte qu'il
faut repenser notre mode de
développement dans un autre rapport au
vivant
elle a dans ce rassemblement plusieurs
profils étaient présents il y avait des
retraités des jeunes étudiants mais
également des enfants venus avec leurs
parents pour débattre écologie un climat
ou encore urbanisme
je vous propose d'écouter ceux à qui
nous avons parlé aujourd'hui c'est
devenu une boîte à fric
une voix tâche pont d'or et on échoue à
nouveau fait l'esclavagisme en secourir
des gens en les faisant monter sur des
podiums on leur fait miroiter des choses
sachant qu'on a des jeux déjà qui
pourrait très bien fonctionner comme la
coupe d'europe comme la coupe du monde
donc nos sportifs sont déjà médaillés et
là on est dans l'immmédiat
l'individualisme total il faut arrêter
cette aberration
à l'époque on se bat pour le climat on
se bat pour le musée de social le sport
n'est plus du tout ce qu'il était et il
est rentable donné la nature et l'homme
est tout ce qu'il ya autour
ça a permis aussi d'être un prétexte
pour démolir des quartiers entiers pour
reconstruire derrière des les éléments
qui ont un rapport assez lointain avec
le sport des jeux olympiques
simplement pour
faire fuir les habitants les plus
pauvres de la région parisienne
à écouter le peuple voilà c'est ça c'est
écouter ce qui va pas et pas rester aux
affaires comme hbo comme bon nous semble
et penser que le peuple pense alors que
c'est faux
vous l'avez entendu cette colère et puis
ce besoin de venir manifester malgré
elle la pluie vraisemblablement il y
avait un peu plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes présentes ici ceux à qui nous
avons pu parler nous aurait également
confié que la soie la loi sécurité
globale pourrait être dangereux si elles
étaient est appliquée notamment lors des
jeux olympiques en 2024 et même si la
plupart à qui nous avons parlé et bien
il nous expliquer qu'il était presque au
sûr que les jeux olympiques ne serait
pas annulé mais qu'ils ne continueront à
manifester à résister là c'est le mans
qui a été utilisée est par ailleurs
plusieurs rassemblements sont prévus
dans les semaines à venir
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans 30 minutes
à tout à l'heure rester avec nous sur
arte france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même